They apply three coats of
oil paint, allowing for
hours of drying time
between coats.
This is a key step
because aside from
providing the background
color, the oil paint
waterproofs the paper.
Next, they varnish the
handle to make it
moisture resistant.
And now for the grand
finale.
An artist paints a
design in vibrant,
waterproof oils.
The themes are
traditional flowers,
animals, landscapes,
people.
No stencils to trace or
patterns to follow.
The artist works
entirely freehand, the
result being that no two
umbrellas are ever
exactly alike.
Each oil paper umbrella
is a portable work of
art. Pretty yet
practical.
Rain or shine.